très bien mes chers collègues je vous
propose que nous
débutions je vous propose
que si vous voulez bien vous vous
asseoir voilà merci propose que nous
débutions notre audition et donc je suis
très heureuse d'AC très heureux pardon
d'accueillir madame vterin ministre donc
et je vous remercie en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation un peu rapide
je rappelle que le texte que nous allons
examiner en séance à parti de la semaine
prochaine a été traité de façon un petit
peu difficile au niveau de la commission
affaires social à la fois parce que le
calendrier était compliqué nous avons eu
à travailler notamment et je pense au
rapporteur pendant la période de fin
d'année donc toujours des conditions
difficiles pour organiser les auditions
malgré ça nos deux rapporteurs Jean sol
et Jine gu ont fait un travail
remarquable puis derrière il y a eu très
rapidement la fin du gouvernement et
donc le rendez-vous initial que nous
avions prévu avec la ministre r Berger a
été annulé très naturellement et voilà
et donc nous avons examiné en en
commission le texte sans avoir eu
l'occasion de dionner ni l'auteur de la
PPL ni la ministre voilà c'était c'était
les mêmes personnes bon voilà voilà et
donc malgré tout moi je tenais à ce
qu'on puisse auditionner vous
auditionner avant l'examen en séance à
la fois parce que ça semble important
d'avoir le regard et la parole du
gouvernement dans ce pour ce type
d'exercice mais également c'était aussi
l'occasion pour nous de de vous entendre
au regard des réactions dans vos prise
de fonction sur le sujet important du
bien vieillir en France et puis c'était
également l'occasion pour nos
rapporteurs bien peut-être en complément
de des travaux qu'ils ont menés d'avoir
un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires à vous poser de façon à
ce que ça nous éclaire préalablement au
démarrage de la séance la semaine
prochaine voilà donc l'exercice alors on
exerce un petit peu au contraint parce
que nous avons un texte en séance de la
commission qui devrait débuter autour de
17h30 donc j'ai prévu déjà nos collègues
que les questions sera assez limité mais
on aura quand même le temps de de poser
des questions ce que je vous propose
madame la ministre c'est commencer par
un poliminaire globalement sur votre
regard sur ce texte de loi je sais que
vous l'avez non pas corédigé puisque
c'est une PPL mais vous l'avez en tout
cas eu dans les mains vous savez sur
l'occasion de l'examiner avoir votre
regard sur cette PPL ensuite nous
donnerons la parole en premier lieu à
nos deux rapporteurs et ensuite nous
ouvrirons le débat pour pouvoir essayer
de clôturer autour de 17h30 17h40 voilà
j'arrête là mes propos madame la
ministre je vous donne la parole
monsieur le Président tout d'abord je
voudrais évidemment vous remercier pour
vos propos je voudrais aussi vous
remercier Monsieur le ent pour votre
accueil dans votre département il y a
quelques jours j'étais très heureuse de
pouvoir faire votre connaissance et
parler avec vous d'un sujet qui était
finalement celui de l'autre âge de la
vie puisque nous étions sur les tout
petits mais c'était intéressant je pense
que nous puissions déjà échanger sur ce
sujet je voudrais évidemment saluer
madame la rapporteur guinaise monsieur
le rapporteur Jean sol et vous dire
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs le plaisir qui est le mien de
vous retrouver alors effectivement il y
a pas de semaines que je suis au
gouvernement euh pour autant j'ai déjà
eu à regarder ces sujets d'autonomie
pour deux raisons je ne vais pas vous
raconter ma vie rassurez-vous mais j'ai
été parlementaire pendant longtemps j'ai
été député j'ai surtout eu l'honneur
d'être au gouvernement et pendant 3 ans
sous des gouvernements rafarin et
Villepin il s'avère que dans l'un des
gouvernements rafarin j'ai été pendant 6
mois c'est la vie ministérielle qui fait
ça en charge précisément des personnes
âgées juste au moment qui était celui de
l'application de la journée de
solidarité et l' près canicule pourquoi
est-ce que je vous dis ça ma vie n'a
aucun intérêt sauf vous dire que à ce
moment-là moi je me souviens bien des
grandes déclarations et des grands
engagements sur l'autonomie et
finalement la manière dont on allait
juger un pays à sa capacité à traiter
nos aînés force de constater que je veis
pas dire je vous retrouve ça serait
d'une maladresse absolue ça n'est pas
vous qui étiez là mais je retrouve le
sujet et force de constater que l'enjeu
du vieillissement reste le même la seule
chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui le dire la
main sur le cœur c'est un peu juste
parce que ce que nous savons c'est que
d'ici quelques années nous aurons plus
de personnes de 65 ans dans notre pays
que de personnes de moins de 15 ans
c'est dire si aujourd'hui nous sommes
quelque part parfaitement rattrapés par
ce sujet et que l'élu local que je suis
encore aujourd'hui mesure au quotidien
le sujet qui est celui de
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
dans notre pays avec un sujet majeur qui
est celui d' dans entendre ce qu'elle
nous demande et ce sujet nous oblige il
nous oblige car pour 90 % d'entre elles
nous disent je veux rester chez moi et
donc quelque part cela nous conduit à
réfléchir à la capacité qui est la nôtre
de prendre ce grand virage qui est celui
du vieillissement de la population et
des réponses que nous pourrions apporter
à nos concitoyens et nous savons que sur
ce sujet évidemment les situations sont
pour le moins hétérogènes qu'on soit
évidemment dans l'Hexagone ou en
métropole qu'on soit en urbanité en
ruralité les sujets les réponses sont
pas les mêmes et quelque part moi je
voudrais évidemment saluer cette
proposition de loi parce qu'elle résume
tout à fait les choses et là c'est le
ministre de la Santé qui va vous le dire
le Bien Vieillir parce qu'effectivement
ce qui doit nous interpeller mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est notre
capacité à accompagner nos concitoyens
du premier au dernier souff dans cette
idée qui est celle de la bonne santé à
tous les âges de la vie et et là nous
sommes évidemment sur des sujets
notamment de prévention et j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure dans les
questions que vous voudraz bien évoquer
mais j'ai regardé avec beaucoup
d'intérêt les réflexions qui sont les
vôtres pour anticiper ces pathologies du
Grand âche qui évidemment plus elles
sont anticipés pe plus on peut l'espérer
peuvent évidemment peut-être pas éviter
mais en tout cas être amoindri et puis
surtout les conséquences qui sont celle
notamment sur un sujet qui lui aussi me
tient à cœur et vous l'avez évoqué et j
j'en dis un mot tout suite c'est celui
du parcours résidentiel parce que bien
sûr rester chez soi c'est très bien mais
encore faut-il que le chez soi soit
adapté alors évidemment comme tout le
monde je connais ou j'ai au moins
entendu parler de ma prime adapte la
question c'est comment cela devient
réalité et j'ai toujours à l'esprit ce
même sujet c'est-à-dire je vais parler
des femmes parce qu'elles sont elles ont
une espérance de vie plus élevée cette
femme seule en ruralité dans une maison
pas isolée avec un étage la chambre à
coucher à l'étage et comme elle le dit
si bien c'est mes meubles et c'est ma
vie je ne veux pas partir et
malheureusement comme le disent les
soignants c'est toujours trop tôt ou
toujours trop tard mais ça n'est jamais
le bon moment pour apporter les réponses
et c'est là où mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs moi je tiens à vous dire que
je suis totalement à votre écoute parce
que nous sommes dans un domaine qui est
celui de l'intime en d'autres termes il
n'y a pas d'injonction vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens il y a une capacité à
réfléchir à quelque chose qui soit
suffisamment attractif pour permettre
effectivement à nos concitoyens de se
dire et ben oui potentiellement ce qu'on
me propose là peut-être intéressant et
c'est là où tout de suite je reviens à
l'échelle qui à mes yeux est celle du
bassin de vie c'est-à-dire que quand on
dit qu'on reste au domicile à ce
moment-là encore faut-il être entouré on
peut pas rester au domicile tout seul et
donc quelle réponse de médicos-social
avons-nous quelle réponse d'aidents
familiaux avons-nous nous le savons nos
familles dans la diversité de ce qu'on
appelle famille aujourd'hui dans le
respect des convictions de chacun nos
familles ont beaucoup évolué et beaucoup
de d'enfants ont des responsabilités ou
des activités ou des choix de vie qui
font qu'ils ne sont pas apportés je vais
employer un mot que je trouve joli à
porter d'embrassade et donc un des
sujets c'est que la solitude de nos
aînés est probablement l'un des
principaux mots et pour celui-là il y a
pas beaucoup de réponse sauf à regarder
quelle réponse on a effectivement par un
accompagnement un suivi qui permet
effectivement de lutter contre cette
solitude alors évidemment pour tout ça
il y a une autre notion à laquelle je
suis très attachée c'est celle de la
reconnaissance de celles et de ceux qui
entourent nos aînés et dans votre
proposition de loi il y a des sujets
matériels tout à fait intéressants et
que je regarde avec beaucoup d'intérêt
qu'il s'agisse de cette carte
professionnelle qu'il s'agisse de cette
prise en charge de transport je crois
que ce sont des sujets sur lesquels
effectivement nous devons aller alors en
ce qui me concerne je vous dirais que je
je suis très attachée à ce qu'on pense
aussi à la formation tout au long de la
vie j'ai bien noté votre idée que je
trouve très intéressante qui est celle
des personnes qui ont qui sont déjà en
poste depuis 2 ans vous avez raison
c'est déjà une vraie expérience et cette
notion de validation des acquis de
l'expérience est importante pourquoi je
vous parle de formation parce que moi je
peux parfaitement entendre qu'on nit pas
envie de passer 10 20 30 40 ans dans ces
métiers d'ailleurs on le voit
aujourd'hui y compris sur la petite
enfance et donc la question qui va se
poser c'est quelle capacité avons-nous à
permettre à ces personnes qui s'engagent
dans les métiers de l'humain qui en plus
je le rappelle sont les métiers du
présentiel là on risque pas de faire du
distantiel il y a une nouvelle inégalité
qui est née et comment avons-nous
capacité là encore à apporter des
réponses enfin sans être trop longue
pour laisser toute la place nécessaire
au dialogue je voudrais également
insister sur un autre point c'est celui
de l'épad je peux pas ne pas dire un mot
sur les épades évidemment il y a une
notion de restauration de confiance il y
a des maladresses qui doivent être
rattrapées la présence des proches dans
les pades c'est évidemment et je
comprends parfaitement le sens de ce que
vous avez pu mettre en avant tout comme
évidemment la confiance n'exclut pas le
contrôle alors la confiance n'exclut pas
le contrôle après vous le savez la
commission des lois monsieur le
Président va nous dire qu'il y a un
principe qui est celui évidemment de la
présomption d'innocence donc il va
falloir que nous soyons en capacité
d'articuler tout ça mais en tout cas je
crois pouvoir dire que l'arrivée à
l'épad se fait de plus en plus tard vous
le savez tous pour des durées moyennes
de séjour de plus en plus courte sur des
pathologies qui sont des pathologies
aujourd'hui de plus en plus lourdes donc
ça nécessite là aussi bien évidemment
une réflexion une adaptation en tout cas
moi je connais évidemment votre
mobilisation ce texte en témoing j' je
vous dirai enfin que cette PPL me paraît
aller tout à fait dans un calendrier qui
me convient d'autant mieux que vous le
savez il y a un engagement sur cette
fameuse oie grand âge alors c'est vous
qui faites la loi vous appliquez donc
nos textes et vous savez que l'article
34 ne prévoit pas à ce stade de capacité
de loi de programmation pour ce type
d'activité il y a donc une saisine du
Conseil d'État qui est en cours donc ma
réponse va être simple soit le Conseil
d'État nous donne la possibilité que ça
s'appelle loi de programmation au quel
cas ça sera une loi de programmation
soit nous n'avons pas la le terme de loi
de programmation comme on peut l'avoir
en matière militaire ça nous empêchera
pas et je prends l'engagement devant
vous de faire une loi grand et qu'elle
soit faite d'ici et voté d'ici la fin de
cette année voilà monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
les quelques éléments que je voulais
partager avec vous très bien Madame la
Ministre j'avoue que la fin de votre
intervention a été entendue avec grande
oreill puisque c'est un sujet qui
revient souvent tous les ans et donc
voilà en tous les cas c'est pour nous un
point essentiel puisque vous allez voir
dans les interventions on va beaucoup en
tout cas évoquer cette cette loi de
programmation cette loi grand âge qui
fait pour nous en tout cas partie des
des prior été concernant le secteur
voilà alors je donne tout de suite la
parole à nos deux rapporteurs Jean sol
et jusine guidez et après j'ouvrirai le
débat madame la ministre bonjour
monsieur le Président mais mes chers
collègues alors j'ai trois questions me
concernant la troisième vous y avez
répondu en partie mais j'y reviendrai
très certainement de manière synthétique
ma première question porte sur les
recommandation du rapport de Dominique
Libau de mars 2002 la proposition de loi
prévoit comme vous le savez la création
d'un service public départemental de
l'autonomie ou spda ce service public
ajouterait selon nous une couche
supplémentaire par-dessus les
dispositifs de coordination déjà
existants cette organisation
marque-t-elle selon vous une étape
transitoire avant une réforme plus plus
profonde he que nous appelons de nos
vœux à terme quel dispositif le spda
a-t-il vocation à remplacer la
commission des affaires sociales a
apporté des modifications au dispositifs
quel regard portez-vous sur notre
proposition de permettre notamment la
mise en place des conférences
territoriales de l'autonomie à un niveau
infra départemental afin de rendre
possible un pilotage à l'échelle des
bass des bassins de vie vous en avez dit
deux mots ma deième question porte sur
la généralisation du programme
icop auquel nous croyons beaucoup une
démarche de repérage et de prévention de
la perte d'autonomie parce qu'il s'agit
bien du sujet de la prévention de la
perte d'autonomie expériment depuis 2019
bien que la Commission a clarifié
l'articulation entre ce programme et les
rendez-vous de prévention les modalité
de cette généralisation reste peu
explicite à notre sens quels sont les
objectifs du déploiement de ce programme
quel seraiit selon vous les acteurs
chargés de sa mise en œuvre quel moyens
seraiit consacrés à ce programme en 2025
et les années suivantes ma trème
question porte vous l'avez compris sur
la proposition de loi qui prévoit
l'adoption avant la fin 2024 puis une
fois tous les 5 ans de la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle pour le
grand âge qui est attendue en tout cas
par toutes les personnes et les secteur
que nous avons auditionné je pense que
c'est le le nœud gordien cette
disposition n'a pas de portée normative
vous l'avez dit puisque le Parlement ne
peut lui-même se lier mais il marque
l'engagement pris par le précédent
gouvernement de présenter un projet de
loi de programmation avant l'été en vue
d'une adoption au second semestre ce
texte est désormais je vous le disais
plus attendu par les acteurs du grand
avage que la proposition de loi
globalement que nous examinons en ce
moment madame la ministre j'ai bien
compris que oui vous sentez-vous lié par
cet engagement de votre prédécesseur
Auror berger quelles sont vos lignes
directrices pour cette future loi de
programmation qui se profile à l'horizon
et qui je répète nous appelons de nos
vux merci très bien Justin guidez
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre le texte propose la création
d'une nouvelle aide financière de la
CNSA au département pour soutenir la
mobilité des professionnels de l'aide à
domicile l'objectif est louable mais
après le concours complémentaire prévu
par la LFSS pour 2024 ce dispositif
viendrait encore complexifier les
relations financières entre la CNSA et
les départements n'est-ce pas incohérent
avec la volonté affichée du gouvernement
de rationaliser les concours financier
de la CNSA à l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement a attribué à cette aide le
second objectif
de contribuer à l'organisation de temps
d'échange et de partage de bonnes
pratiques au profit des professionnels
de l'aide à domicile serez-vous
favorable à un amendement rattachant ce
second volet de l'aide à un dispositif
existant dans lequel il aurait davantage
sa place par exemple la dotation qualité
pouvant être attribué au service
autonomie à domicile le gouvernement
aussi a prévu par un amendement adopté
en séance publique à l'Assemblée
nationale l'expérimentation par les
départements volontaires d'un
financement des services d'aide et
d'accompagnement à domicile sous forme
de dotation globale or il ressort de nos
auditions une appréciation assez mitigée
du secteur sur une nouvelle
expérimentation de 4 ans après celle qui
a déjà été menée dès 2012 et le constat
qu'il est urgent de réformer plus
profondément le financement des services
à domicile étant donné leur situation
économique la Commission a avancé au 31
décembre 2025 le terme de ces
expérimentations c'est vrai qu'on on
expérimente beaucoup au gouvernement les
problèmes posés par la tarification des
services à domicile étant déjà bien
identifié et leur restructuration étant
déjà en cours vous paraît-il possible
d'engager à cette échéance une réforme
pérenne quel est selon vous le modèle
vers lequel il faut tendre enfin ma
question suivante portera sur le
contrôle des antécédents judiciaires
dans le secteur médico-social en
audition devant notre commission
l'ancienne secrétaire d'État charlotte
cobel a relevé le défi que représentait
la application de la loi du 7 février
2022 qui prévoit le criblage de
plusieurs millions de personnes
travaillant au contact avec des mineurs
la proposition de loi prévoit donc
d'étendre ces contrôles aux intervenants
des structures prenant en charge des
majeurs vulnérables ce qui correspond un
public supplémentaire d'un million de
personnes environ à quelle échéance les
contrôles seront-ils étendus aux
structures accueillant des majeurs
vulnérabl et quelle disposition
prenez-vous afin de vous assurer que les
moyens notamment humains seront
suffisants pour rendre effectif ces
contrôles je vous remercie madame le
ministre je vous propose de répondre à
ces premières questions merci monsieur
le Président alors la première question
de monsieur le rapporteur me permet
finalement de faire un lien avec une
bonne partie des questions de Madame
guidess parce que si je vais leur mettre
un chapeau c'est le sujet de relation
avec les départements et très
concrètement mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs moi la lecture que j'ai c'est
que aujourd'hui j'ai double discussion à
ouvrir avec les départements puisque
vous l'avez compris j'ai à la fois la
responsabilité du travail vous
connaissez la place des départements sur
notamment les sujets des minimas sociaux
et j'ai de l'autre côté le sujet de
l'autonomie c'est dire si à mes yeux
aujourd'hui la nécessité c'est de
retravailler avec les départements sur
globalement qui finance quoi et pourquoi
et comment de façon à remettre d'une
part je pense que il est important
d'entendre l'expérimentation de pas
l'expérimentation l'expérience de prox
imité qui est celle des départements
puisque c'est eux qui au quotidien gèent
et effectivement monsieur le sénateur
sol évoquait la notion de la conférence
territoriale infradépartementale
pourquoi parce que à ce moment-là on
voit bien que c'est nous qui adaptons
notre structure administrative à
l'échelle du bassin de vie en d'autres
termes nos concitoyens ne décident pas
d'habiter auprès de tel ou tel
département ils décident d'habiter à un
endroit et c'est à nous d'apporter la
réponse donc je pense que là-dessus il y
a madame la sénatrice une réflexion
globale à mener et ça fera à mon avis
tout à fait partie de cette loi qui
devra et je parle évidemment non pas de
la PPL mais du projet de loi qui devra
regarder le lien entre les départements
et l'État sur les financements et sur ce
virage autour du vieillissement
maintenant sur le point que vous avez
mis en avant dans votre PPL je crois
qu'il est intéressant de regarder
comment à court terme nous avons cette
capacité d'accompagner la prise en
charge effectivement sur les deux sur
l'élément NOTAM du transport parce que
je sais combien que ce soit le prix des
carburants ou voir évidemment tout
simplement le prix des transports public
il y a là une prise en charge à
effectuer notamment par l'employeur qui
me paraît tout à fait importante en
terme de de transport public par exemple
sur la partie icop c'est une
expérimentation je le sais qui est en
cours le rapport d'évaluation va être
rendu en octobre 24 moi je crois qu'on a
là quelque chose de de tout à fait
intéressant qui nous permet très
concrètement d'avoir une réflexion sur
comment nous anticipons les pathologies
du grand âge et à ce titre-là je ne vois
que des avantages à avancer sur ce point
sur le projet de loi je crois que je
vous ai répondu oui l'idée c'est de
réunir et d'auditionner les uns et les
autres pour être en capacité d'écrire
puisque ce sera un projet de loi et
ensuite de le discuter en 2uxème partie
d'année vous connaissez par cœur le
sujet qui est celui euh du calendrier
euh parlementaire on a quelques
obligations en 2è sem semestre pour
autant le sujet c'est d'être en capacité
de pouvoir le faire donc ça fait partie
des sujets sur lesquels je souhaite
avancer sur le contrôle des antécédents
judiciaires madame la sénatrice j'ai à
deux deux réponses la première c'est la
capacité qu'on peut avoir bien
évidemment de avant d'embaucher
quelqu'un de vérifier ça jeaoudrais dire
que c'est assez facile le deème point et
je suis prudente parce que je n'ai pas
et j'ai pas l'habitude de de dire ce que
je ne peux pas faire c'est pas moi qui
déciderai la capacité ou pas de la
sanction dès lors qu'il y a un problème
je pense que il y ait une notion de
vigilance immédiate de signalement bien
sûr après c'est pour ça que j'y faisais
allusion tout à l'heure la présomption
d'innocence existe donc il va falloir
qu'on trouve une articulation entre ce
respect de la présomption d'innocence et
la mise en sécurité de personnes qui
sont plus vulnérables que d'autres et
pour lesquels s'il y a le moindre doute
il faut évidemment faire très attention
mais je ne veux pas aller plus loin
aujourd'hui je ne serais pas honnête si
je vous disais que j'ai capacité comme
ça aller plus loin en tout cas je
partage complètement la préoccupation
qui est la
vôre très bien Madame ministre je vais
donner tout de suite la parole à
Dominique
Théophile madame la ministre j'aurais
souhaité vous entendre sur les autres
mèes et plus précisément sur la
Guadeloupe et la Martinique qui font
face un vieillissement marqué de leur
population selon les prévisions de l'INC
à l'horizon 2030
près de 30 % de la population
guadeloupéenne sera âgée de 65 ans et
plus ce qui représente plus de 100000
personnes don 28000 seront en perte
d'autonomie 100000 personnes sur environ
300 et quelques000
habitants le vieillissement de la
population est si rapide dans les
Antilles que la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique passeront d'ici 2050
directement des départements parmi les
plus jeunes aux deux départements les
plus âgés de France si je me retrouve
ouve évidemment dans l'esprit de ce
texte il est évident qu'il ne SAA seul
répondre au défis du vieillissement dans
ces territoires la question des moyens
et des moyens humains en particulier se
posent inévitablement en particulier
dans le domaine du soin à domicile une
grosse difficulté ainsi j'aurais
souhaité connaître vos intentions sur
cette question en sachant qu'un plan de
soutien à l'offre médico-social pour les
personnes âgées en autreem et en Corse
2022 a été décidé dans le cadre de la
stratégie bien
vieillir très bien très bien la parole à
Corine
Ferré merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je veux saluer votre venue
parmi nous vous remercier de nous
consacrer un peu de votre temps car nous
sommes effectivement à la veille de
l'examen d'un d'une proposition de loi
sur le Bien Vieillir qui répond très
très très partiellement à un vrai projet
de loi sur les personnes âgées sur
l'autonomie que nous attendons depuis
plus de 6 ans maintenant et donc voilà
on avance tout doucement pas sûrement
mais tout doucement j'aurai quelques
questions et vos réponses permettront
peut-être de lever mon mes
inquiétudes quelques questions parce que
j'ai écouté attentivement le président
de la République lors de sa conférence
de presse la semaine passée il n'a pas
dit un mot sur le sujet de personnes
âgées et sur le sujet de la question la
question de l'autonomie à notre à mon
grand regret à notre grand regret donc
je veux aussi vous interroger
permettez-moi de le faire très
directement je suis sénatrice du
Calvados du Grand Ouest et la presse
régional vous interviewz ce dimanche sur
vos nouvelles fonctions dans vos grands
grands ministères très important le
travail la santé la solidarité et puis
une question vous a été posée sur la loi
de programmation du grand âge qui a été
reporté à plusieurs reprises et très
précisément le journaliste vous
demandait présenterez-vous au Parlement
cette loi cette année vous avez répondu
l'agenda reste à définir alors je suis
inquiète parce que dans cette
proposition de loi que nous allons
examiner à partir de mardi à l'article 2
bis B il est clairement indiqué que
avant le 31 décembre 2024 puis tous les
5 ans une mois de programmation
pluriannuel sur le grand âge déterminera
la trajectoire des finances publiques
donc c'est c'est un engagement qui
pourrait être pris que nous avons adopté
en commission et puis que nous nous
évoquerons donc en séance et ma question
est de savoir est-ce que cet engagement
sera tenu vous avez répondu d'une
certaine façon à mon collègue mais pas
totalement parce que un projet de loi
vous évoquez un projet de
loi pourrait donc être abordé évoqué
d'ici la fin de l'année mais un projet
de loi qui devrait aussi annoncer un
engagement ou des engagements financier
on sait bien que les attentes et vous
avez dit connaître le sujet depuis de
nombreuses années moi je vous parle de
ce gouvernement-ci et ce que nous savons
depuis maintenant 6 7 ans après les
nombreux rapports qui ont été commis par
différents
interlocuteur on connaît la situation on
sait que la la population française est
vieillissante on sait qu'il y a des
besoins essentiels extrêmement important
on sait aussi certes après la création
de la 5e branche on sait aussi
qu'aujourd'hui les les Mo et les
finances ne sont pas là pour répondre à
cet enjeu un véritable défi de société
que de répondre à la prise en charge
l'accompagnement des personnes des
personnes âgées alors si ça n'est plus
un projet de loi ou peut-être allez-vous
nous le préciser qui aborde la question
des finances et bien je je m'interroge
je suis inquiète car nous aurions je
parle au conditionnel nous aurions perdu
une année supplémentaire tout d'abord
une proposition de loi en avril dernier
er modifié complété à l'Assemblée
nationale passant de 13 articles à 60
articles maintenant arrivé au Sénat et
puis voilà
2024 je je reprends encore une fois
votre réponse précisant que l'agenda
restait à à préciser à à définir et puis
je m'inquiète aussi sur le rôle même que
nous avons en tant que parlementaire car
dans cette même réponse je suis désolé
hein je je je lis factuellement dans
cette même réponse vous avez
indiquer vous leur apporter des réponses
concrètes par la voie réglementaire car
la loi car on ne passe pas tout par la
loi or nous considérons je me permets de
le dire au nom de l'ensemble de mes
collègues parlementaires nous
considérons que le Parlement a un rôle
essentiel quand on parle de loin quand
on parle de sujet de société de défi de
société nous devons pouvoir exercer
notre rôle de parlementaire merci Madame
très bien la parole à rond
pourémonge merci monsieur le Président
bonjour madame la ministre alors
effectivement pour pour faire suite à ce
que vient de dire ma ma collègue il y a
un problème d'ordre enfin c'est-à-dire
que cette loi cette loi qu'on l'aelle de
loi de programmation ou grande loi de du
grand âge elle devrait désormais être
avant ce genre de PPL parce que on est
confronté à quoi c'est-à-dire que dans
les PLFSS on a des mesures des
mesurettes des choses très positives
souvent bon voilà des petits des petits
pas dans la bonne direction enfin dans
la bonne direction d'une direction qui
n'est pas définie puisqueune loi quand
même trace les axes stratégiques il il
trace aussi les grands axes de la
gouvernance et puis
euh à la fin et pas le moindre il trace
aussi le financement qui est là donc on
se trouve là avec des choses beaucoup de
de mesures qui auraient eu leur place
dans un PLFSS qui est un peu là pour
décliner dans une perspective de moyen
terme bien ce qu'on peut faire les pas
qu'on peut réaliser d'année en année moi
cette loi de programmation je l'ai dit
dans mon dans les amendements de séance
de si ça doit être vraiment une grande
loi stratégique de gouvernance de
financement euh c'est de la branche
autonomie c'est une loi de programmation
de la branche autonomie donc il me
semble qu'elle devrait embrasser tous
les champs de l'autonomie euh et
notamment aussi des personnes
handicapées hein c'est parce
queautrement on fait un pas en arrière
quoi on fait une CNSA on fait beaucoup
de dispositifs comme le CDPA comme les
beaucoup de d'autres dispositifs qui
sont intégrés sur ces deux publics et
puis on traite encore les choses en silo
alors qu'on sait que il faut
décloisonner et bien entendu après comme
par hasard on a un amendement qui dit ah
faut aussi parler des personnes en
situation de handicap qui vieillissent
enfin bon là bien sûr a terb égal voilà
donc on voit bien qu'il y a quelque
chose quand même d'une révolution
qui porte sur l'autonomie qui n'est pas
gérée et qui est encore géré en en silo
moi je vais profiter du fait que vous
êtes bizarrement aussi ministre du
Travail B ma foi c'est vrai qu'à la fin
à force de grouper on en aura peut-être
plus qu'un mais j'ai peur que ça soit le
président donc gardons encore un petit
peu cela et bien ça vous permettra que
quand même de peut-être de vous atteler
parce qu'on parle de crise
d'attractivité dans le secteur certes
vous dites il y a des personnes qui
veulent faire un parcours bah oui il y
en a qui le font elles sont aides à
domicile passent être soignante enfin ça
c'est un peu un peu le même niveau mais
elle devient infirmière j'ai même des
gens qui ont eu qui sont allés jusque
jusqu'à la psychologue donc bon il faut
effectivement décloisonner pour
permettre ses parcours professionnels
mais je voudis il est temps peut-être
parce que vous êtes ministre du Travail
de voir ce que les comment dire les les
conséquences DL TER des distorsions de
concurrence entre vos dispositifs bon
les conventions collectives c'est leur
rôle mais le fameux Ségure qui a été
effectivement pas donné à l'aide à
domicile sous prétexte que elle avait
son avenant 43 alors que les épades
l'avaient alors même que elles aussi
elles avaient des avancées
conventionnelles je crois savoir que
d'ailleurs toutes les fédérations ont
appelé à une déclaration unilatérale
employeur pour dire qu'elles allaient
appliquer enfin le segure parce que on a
vu effectivement des transferts de
personnes d'un secteur à l'autre ben
puisque vous êtes ministre du Travail il
va peut-être falloir que ça fait
longtemps qu'on le dénonce ça fait
longtemps que les fédérations le
dénoncent des des concurrences de
missile épad épad autres dispositifs
donc il faut vraiment si vous voulez ce
parcours ce parcours de la personnes
vulnérables sans rupture il faut pas
aussi que les personnels eux créent
comme ça des poches de de distorsion
concurrentielle et puis il faut aussi
puisque vous êtes ministre du Travail et
bien j'espère que vous ferez pas comme
votre vos prédécesseurs qui ont tardé
des années durant à agréer et ça ça
dépendait du ministre du Travail
l'avenant 43 et qui ont plongé le
secteur dans une crise d'attractivité
dont ils ne se sont pas remis parce que
les gens qui démissionnent ils
reviennent pas le on a signé cet accord
enfin on a signé à l'époque j'étais
directrice générale euh et pendant des
années on vous a demandé de l'agréer
enfin c'est donc maintenant d'ailleurs
j'ai j'ai déjà prévenu les fédération et
je vais terminer là-dessus que puisque
vous avez la solidarité et le travail
les avenant seront agréés au plus
vite on essaie quand même de concentrer
sur le le texte hein voilà alors Pascal
runi merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre bon moi j'ai partagé vos
moments de ministre déjà donc je connais
votre force de travail de persuasion et
votre courage donc j'espère que je ne
serai pas déçu
voilà alors moi j'ai alors c'est pas
vraiment des des questions mais j'ai un
sujet de préoccupation je suis au
conseil départemental donc de l'INE où
on a des moyens financiers très très
faibles et et aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
de litpad qui qui sont vides et on est
en train de fermer un épad qui est à
côté de de Saint-Quentin parce que bien
entendu et moi je je comprends
aujourd'hui les personnes veulent rester
dans leur domicile le plus longtemps
possible ce qui veut dire donc de
prendre en charge tout ce qui est soins
soins domicile mais nous au département
on pourra pas pas continuer à à soutenir
les épades et à la fois les les soins à
domicile donc c'est une réflexion à voir
d' d'autre part dans les épades
aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus
médicalisé donc est-ce que c'est encore
un sujet de département ou est-ce que
c'est pas pl plôt lié à à l'hôpital et
et enfin juste là pour les alertes en
fait qui sont faites sur la maltraitance
moi je peux vous dire que j'ai je fais
ça pour quelqu'un de ma famille bon je
crois qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui abandonnent voilà donc il faudrait
simplifier le le système et puis
j'apprécie bien sûr que vous êtes
mobilisé aussi sur la prévention qui
comme vous êtes ministre de la santé
c'est prévention partout quoi parce que
je trouve qu'on est assez en retard en
fait sur ces sur ces sujets mais ça
concerne pas que les personnes
vieifiantes c'est aussi médecine du
travail et cetera voilà merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame la ministre je
propose de répondre à cette première de
question il y aura encore quatre
intervenants après hein merci merci
monsieur le Président alors plusieurs
réponses à Monsieur théophil je dirais
que effectivement la situation d'outremè
mérite d'être regardée j'ai noté
évidemment avec intérêt vos commentaires
qui concernent les sujets plus
particulièrement de la Guadeloupe et je
pense que un des éléments sur lesquels
il faut que nous travaillons et c'est là
où je vois tout à fait l'intérêt entre à
la fois le ministère du Travail et le
ministère des solidarité car on a aussi
tout un sujet de taux de chômage et une
de nos questions c'est notre capacité à
former un certain nombre de personnes
qui pourraient avec une formation aller
vers des emplois c'est pas la seule
solution mais on sait très bien qu'en
matière de grand âge un des sujets c'est
le moyen humain c'estes moyens humains
il faut qu'on se donne les moyens en
outreemre comme évident
dans l'Hexagone de trouver des solutions
et c'est en tout cas pour moi un des
points tout à fait importants en ce qui
concerne madame Ferré alors
effectivement madame j'ai dit qu'il y
avait un agenda à définir et je vous dis
pourquoi je crois l'avoir expliqué tout
à l'heure mais j'y reviens tout
simplement parce que le terme de loi de
programmation au moment où nous parlons
ne peut pas être utilisé parce que
l'article 34 de notre Constitution ne le
prévoit pas et donc mon sujet c'est
c'est d'attendre le retour du Conseil
d'État que je devrais avoir je pense
d'ici un mois et à partir de là
l'engagement précis que je prends devant
vous c'est effectivement à ce moment-là
de faire une loi grand âge qui n'aura
pas le terme programmation si le Conseil
d'État ne m'y autorise pas cette loi ce
que je peux d'ors et déjà vous dire
c'est que pour moi elle a trois éléments
clés la stratégie les finances et la
gouvernance en d'autres termes en
d'autres termes quelle virage
domiciliaire et surtout avec qui et ça
me permet de répondre au sujet qui est
celui que madame grenny a bien voulu
évoquer j'étais madame grunny à La
Capelle samedi après-midi avec votre
président de département qui n'a pas
manqué de m'expliquer que le département
de l'INE avait une épargne net négative
et donc c'est dire si effectivement le
sujet est tout à fait important et donc
très concrètement je pense que un des
sujets de ce texte c'est l'occasion
effectivement de repenser globalement le
sujet et c'est en tout cas dans cet
esprit là que je souhaite l'évoquer
alors je veux redire également que la
notion de la voie règlementaire elle est
simplement là parce que pardonnez-moi
mais de temps à autre il y a des sujets
qui peuvent effectivement se réglé par
voie réglementaire et dans ces cas-là le
sujet n'est pas d'éviter la loi le sujet
il est de mettre dans la loi ce qui
relève de la loi qui normalement est le
cadre pour ensuite décliner donc je
pense que c'est cette étape là qui me
paraît être dans le bon sens on on a une
vision on la partage on la discute les
parlementaires votent un texte ensuite
on applique le texte et en fonction de
la façon dont le texte est écrit il y a
une partie qui peut-être une partie
réglementaire alors ensuite sur le sujet
moi je crois pas que ça soit bizarre
d'être en charge à la fois du travail et
de des solidarités et de la santé mais
qu'au contraire c'est un continuum et
que quelque part ça me donne une
responsabilité d'articuler l'ensemble de
ces directions pour apporter des
réponses qui soient des réponses
importantes et là il y a deux notions de
parcours il y a la notion de parcours de
nos concitoyens les plus âgés mais il y
a aussi le parcours professionnel de
celles et ceux qui s'engagent dans ces
métiers et je continue à dire madame la
sénatrice que certes il y a des gens qui
effectivement vont évoluer dans leur
formation professionnel mais il y a des
gens qui ont envie qui peuvent avoir le
droit d'arrêter et de faire autre chose
et je vous donne un exemple quand on
parle d'assistants médicaux peut-être
que quand je vais prendre un exemple
très simple quand on en a parlé l'autre
jour àartenis quand on a euh 60 ans on a
plus forcément physiquement la capacité
à se baisser pour porter un bébé le
ramener et cetera par contre on a
peut-être capacité à être l'assistant
médical du médecin de prendre les
constantes et de faire ce lien vous
voyez c'est ce continuum qu'il faut que
nous soyons en capacité de mettre en
place il y a il y a une approche qui est
une approche qui est celle de des
métiers de l'humain et les formations
des métiers de l'humain qui apportent
des
réponses très bien Madame le Ministre
alors la parole à isisabeth douanau
notre rapporteur général oui merci
monsieur le président je voudrais
m'associer au au propos de notre
président pour vous accueillir madame la
ministre et nous aurons donc l'occasion
de travailler avec saisonalité parce que
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale loi d'approbation nous
oblige à nous revoir dans l'année je je
voudrais dire cette proposition de loi
en fait elle répond à certaines question
effectivement mais il y a tellement de
frustration dans le domaine du
vieillissement de la population parce
par que tellement de gouvernements ont
successivement promis une loi grand âge
que on le sait chacun chacune pourrait
trouver en fait à à à à se à faire son m
à coulep parce que je pense que c'est
une épreuve collective en fait il faut
aussi quand on on on on veut prendre à
bras le corps un tel sujet et bien il
faut y consacrer beaucoup beaucoup de
d'argent et il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui
il faut trouver l'argent et on on le
voit bien à chaque PLFSS le déficit
programmé ne permet pas souvent de
dégager des marges suffisantes bon ceci
étant dit je je je pense que si vous
avez l'intention parce que là j'ai bien
senti la volonté maintenant il faudra
effectivement trouver les moyens et bien
là où il y a volonté il y a un chemin
oui c'est ça on connaît tout ça ce que
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il faut
absolument répondre euh à l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui sur le terrain
qu'est-ce qu'on entend beaucoup c'est le
problème du recrutement des
professionnels de santé vous parler de
continuum c'est une question aussi bien
sûr mais c'est surtout le recrutement et
c'est surtout les moyens donnés aux
établissements et surtout donner la la
la perspective aux établissements parce
que moi j'entends bien cette histoire de
du domiciliaire et je pense qu'on peut
tous témoigner que on voudra tous rester
le plus longtemps possible au domicile
mais pour autant il faut pas condamner
les établissements parce que nous aurons
de plus en plus de centenaires de
nonagénire et cetera bien sûr qu'on
arrivera plus vieux et on restera moins
longtemps dans les établissements mais
c'est la peur aujourd'hui de beaucoup de
d'établissements vis-à-vis de leur
département qui sont un peu en
difficulté ou ou voir beaucoup en
difficulté sur le plan budgétaire donc
il faut leur donner des perspectives et
s'il y a une loi de programmation il
faudra absolument soutenir ce ce comment
cette cet ensemble de de de compéten
d'emploi qui est essentiel sur nos
territoire moi je je je veux le le redir
euh sur cette PPL moi j'aurais souhaité
un petit peu plus euh de de moyens sur
la mobilité on parle de la mobilité des
professionnels mais on parle pas
tellement de la mobilité des personnes
âgées en fait et c'est souvent une
grande difficulté à un moment donné ils
peuvent plus conduire et il faut se
rendre à des rendez-vous médicaux il
faut se rendre voilà et et ils ont pas
toujours la famille comme vous l'avez
dit à proximité et je trouve qu'il y a
peut-être un petit un petit manque dans
dans dans cette PPL sur ce ce plan là il
y a des associations qui aujourd'hui sur
les territoires ont des initiatives
formidables et qui sont pas forcément
soutenu ni par les départements ni par
la CNSA enfin voilà je trouve que c'est
et la part aussi qui est trop peu donné
au paramédical parce que je pense que le
paramédical a en terme de prévention un
vrai rôle à jouer et je trouve que là
c'est sans doute un peu un angle mort
merci beaucoup la parole à Corine
boursier merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre j'aimerais vous
interroger sur les moyens de lutter
concrètement selon vous contre la
maltraitance en épade la PPL contient
surtout des mesures pour lutter contre
la maltraitance en améliorant le
signalement et le traitement de ces
signalements mais une politique efficace
consisterait à prévenir la maltraitance
afin qu'il n'y ait justement rien à
signaler quels sont les leviers
possibles selon vous qui n'existent pas
encore le personnel en établissement
reçoit déjà des formations sur la
bientraitance l'établissement doit
désigner un référent bienraitance le
numéro d'appel contre la maltraitance
doit être affiché dans l'établissement
et cetera mais force est de constater
que cela ne suffit pas en effet au de
au-delà de la maltraitance que je
qualifierai entre parenèse de volontaire
qui peut exister de la part du personnel
une part importante du phénomène
consiste surtout en une maltraitance
dont je dirais qu'elle est entre
guillemets
involontaire qui résulte surtout du
manque de temps du personnel et de leur
insuffisance en nombrant aussi afin de
prévenir la maltraitance la solution la
plus efficace ne serait-elle pas de
garantir un nombre de soignants par
établissement en fonction de son niveau
de dépendance et de renforcer la
formation des soignants en sait cela dit
qu'une telle mesure sorterait aux
difficultés de recrutement déjà
existante et qu'elle pose aussi la
question de l'attractivité et de la
revalorisation de la profession je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole à
Cathy
poursopoli merci monsieur le Président
bonjour madame la ministre alors madame
la ministre je pense qu'on on va avoir
l'occasion de se revoir parce que j'ai
vu finalement vous aviez présenté votre
feuille de route dans ouest-fance hein
votre feuille de route sur une grande
politique nationale de santé et donc
évidemment il est pour les
parlementaires que nous sommes nous
lisons la presse nous aimons bien
découvrir les choses en ouest-fance mais
je pense que ce serait bien aussi que
vous puissiez évidemment mais je pense
que c'est votre intention de venir dans
devant le Sénat pour présenter votre
feuille de route parce que
hormis cette PPL auabé sur bien vieillir
que nous aurons euh nous avons des
sujets qui nous préoccupent je parle de
l'hôpital public je parle de l'accès aux
soins je parle de la pénurie des
médicaments je parle de la santé au
travail je parle du droit au travail
donc tout ça évidemment nous y
reviendrons quand vous nous présenterez
votre feuille de route euh concernant
madame la
ministre la loi de programmation sur la
perte
d'autonomie vous pensez bien que nous
pour ma part
avec ma collègue Sylvana syvan nous
avons quelques doutes parce que nous
avons connu 6 ministres en 50 ans euh
c'est beaucoup hein en 50 ans c'est ce
que j'ai dit en 5 ans de
en 5
années mais je parle un peu chti hein
madame la ministre en en 5 années nous
avons connu six ministres et chaque fois
il faut bien se le dire que nous avons
eu un nouveau ministre il est ici venu
nous présenter cette loi autonomie grand
âge et cette loi autonomie grand âge au
bout du 6e ministre nous ne la voyons
toujours pas donc nous espérons de tous
nos vœux cette loi autonomi grandâche
parce que il faut bien se le dire nous
sommes confrontés à des soucis des
problèmes graves on avait vu à quel
point il y avait il pouvait y avoir de
la maltraitance je pense à cette ces
épades lucratifes que nous avions
auditionné pour ne pas les citer révélés
dans le livre de Victor Castanet qui
avec des fonds publics
s'octroyer des salaires faut-il le
rappeler indécent mais qui en plus de
ça n'avait pas pas assez pas du tout
même pratiquement de personnel dans les
épades et où il y avait une
maltraitance qui était quand même assez
scandaleuse donc nous appelons de nos
vœux nous cette loi grand âge
autonomie il y aurait beaucoup de choses
à dire et je ne peux pas les dire parce
que je seraiis trop longue parce que il
y a des problèmes aujourd'hui de
recrutement chez les aides à domicile
il y a le problème des salaires qui sont
posés dans les dans les éepades et nous
avons tous et toutes dans nos
territoires un gros problème de
recrutement dans ces métiers alors
madame la ministre moi je vais vous
poser une petite question juste
une allez-vous financer notre protection
sociale à son juste niveau en remettant
en cause les 87 milliards d'euros
d'exonération de cotisation sociale pour
les employeurs ce qui évidemment vient
viendrait apporter un gros plus à notre
budget de la Sécurité sociale je vous
remercie merci pour votre constance
madameop alors la parole à Véronique
guillota oui merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre en tout cas merci
d'être présente 10 jours après votre
votre nomination je pense qu'on peut le
le saluer même s'il y a des articles je
comprends que vous puissiez être
interrogé par la presse et ne pas dire
que vous n'allez pas répondre parce que
vous n'êtes pas encore allé au Sénat
donc voilà en tout cas moi je voudrais
témoigner également du du de votre de la
connaissance en tout cas du de la
capacité de travail dont vous faites
preuve sur votre territoire et le
volontarisme donc je pense que s'il est
mise s'il est mis en tout cas à
l'épreuve d'une loi grand âge voilà on
devrait pouvoir on devrait pouvoir
avancer moi je voudrais c'est pas c'est
pas vraiment une question j'ai j'ai une
remarque à faire en fait c'estes lois
grand âge c'est éminemment transversal
alors ça prend en compte la prévention
ça prend en compte l'Habitat vous on l'a
dit ça prend en compte la formation de
de nos professionnel de santé tout le
volet social et en fait il y a un volet
aménagement du territoire avec la
mobilité on en a on l'a également évoqué
dans la mobilité j'ai un sujet alors je
ne sais pas j'étais médecin co en épad
il y a quelques années on avait
effectivement un souci de mobilité des
personnes âgées pour les amener tout
simplement sur des consultes dentaires
alors je l'avais déjà fait remonter je
ne sais pas si ça a bougé mais je ne
crois pas et du coup il y a des
personnes âgées aujourd'hui qui
n'arrivve pas à aller se faire faire
enfin en tout cas traiter leur hygiène
bucoddentaire qui entraîne voilà toutes
les problématiques que l'on connaît
parce que le transport est encore payant
je pense qu'il y a des petites choses
comme ça qui sont pas de la législation
à mon avis mais du réglementaire qui
pourrait être rapidement levé concernant
la prévention j'ai également on a vu
avancer des choses sur l'activité
physique adaptée pour les patientses
atteints de cancer je pense que c'est
une piste peut-être à explorer lorsque
les les les consultations de prévention
émettent des des sujets de fragilité je
pense que derrière on pourrait quand
même étendre peut-être cette activité
physique adaptée en tout cas la la
rembourser pour pour ces types de
patients pour travailler sur la préven
et enfin peut-être quelque chose de de
plus plus important enfin quoi tout tout
est important c'est le le volet du
virage
domiciliaire effectivement toutes les
personnes aujourd'hui souhaitent
quasiment vivre à domicile le plus
souvent possible et quand on soigne des
personnes âgées ce qu'on s'aperçoit
quand même c'est que elle
malheureusement la fin de vie se termine
plus que majoritairement à l'hôpital
donc on voit bien qu'à un moment donné
on a un trou dans la raquette et qu'on
n'arrive pas par manque d'accompagnement
des aidentss par le fait de rassurer de
parler du décès aussi parce que le Bien
Vieillir on a derrière également
malheureusement le le bien mourir quoi
et et tout ça fait qu'il y a un moment
donné de rupture on a beau faire ce que
l'on veut pour l'instant on n'a pas
réussi à le résoudre donc je crois qu'il
y a cette périodelà qu'il va falloir
également travailler ça a été dit les
ressources humaines je pense que c'est
le le le baba et l'alpha et l'oméga du
maintien à domicile de nos personnes
âgées et concernant les épades est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas une réflexion à voir
sur des épad dors les murs alors qui
permettrai de répondre un peu à ce que
la rapporteur ellisabeth a a a soumis
c'est-à-dire continue à mobiliser les
ressources des épades pour avoir des
pades des places d'épades à l'extérieur
enfin des épad dors les murs parce que
la difficulté quand vous avez une
personne à domicile c'est la
coordination des soins c'estd qu'à un
moment donné on cherche le médecin on
l'a pas la personne qui est les dents
est des fois aussi âgée que la personne
qui est la personne vieillissante on
appelle sur une plateforme le médecin
répond pas l'infirmière n'est pas passée
on appelle le 15 on va à l'hôpital et en
fait la rupture du parcours se fait donc
je pense qu'il y aurait une une forme de
transition d'pad aussi peut-être à
imaginer et ça pourrait être dans voilà
ça pourrait peut-être faire partie de la
réflexion de cette loi cette loi
grandage très bien merci donc et la
dernière intervenante qui est Corine
hbert notre rapporteur de la branche
maladie merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre merci d'être devant
nous ce soir alors contrairement à
Pascal grunny je ne vous connais pas
mais comme elle j'espère ne pas être
déçu
voilà alors j'aurai deux petites
questions et puis et puis une remarque
euh la première question elle est très
courte quel est votre regard sur
l'accueil
familial la deuxième elle concerne ce
qui a été voté dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en en
2022 c'est-à-dire
euh les les nouveaux services autonomie
à domicile et l'obligation pour les
siades de se rapprocher de service
d'aide à
domicile le décret d'application est
paru en juillet je crois mi juuillet
l'année dernière alors juste parenthèse
il est imbuvable mais ça ça c'est voilà
mais concrètement sur le terrain on voit
toutes les difficultés pour les services
de se rapprocher pour des questions de
périmètrre pour des questions de statut
des salariés êtes-vous prêt dans le
casadre de cette proposition de loi à
assouplir ce qui existe aujourd'hui et à
faire que ce rapprochement reste une
possibilité mais pas une obligation
voilà mes deux questions sont très
courtes et enfin une remarque si vous le
permettez puisque la loi grandage
autonomie a été largement
évoqué j'espère madame la ministre que
que vous n'aurait pas la posture cont
tenu de la
situation qui s'est dégradée pour les
conseils départementaux vous le savez ça
a été évoqué euh à dire en abordant ce
ce projet de loi que vous allez écrire
que puisque c'est une compétence des
département à chaque fois que l'État
mettra un € il faudra que les
département mettent 1 €. voilà c'était
une posture de l'une de vos
prédécesseurs j'espère que
vous comment cette dynamique oui alors
si c'est pour dire l'état M 1 et le
département bê 2 faudra pas compter sur
le Sénat très bien Madame la mère madame
la ministre je vous propose de répondre
à cette dernière série de questions
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs pour
vos interventions alors peut-être en
intervention liumière je rappelle que je
suis élu local donc si vous voulez c'est
quand même des sujets que je vis au
quotidien je fais pas que les entendre
et les lire et je pense que là-dessus on
a tous des expériences et je pense que
c'est quand même la meilleure que celle
qu'on vit au quotidien une fois que que
j'ai dit cela madame bourtier
effectivement je par le sujet de la
maladresse et et de la maltraitance la
question c'est effectivement comment on
arrive à faire la limite entre les deux
l'exaspération la fatigue c'est un vous
avez raison là-dessus je pense qu'il y a
deux sujets il y a un sujet de formation
je le partage avec vous et il y a un
terme que je prends avec énormément de
réserves je vous voyez que je m'arrête
et que je vous dis ave beaucoup de
réserves mais ça me permet de répondre
que j'étais déjà au Sénat la semaine
dernière et mercredi dernier sur la
proposition de résolution de votre
collègue Nathalie de lâre pour faire de
la p Catherine grande cause nationale
pourquoi est-ce que je je fais ce détour
pour vous dire qu'on a aussi ces sujets
là qui est l'évolution malheureusement
on voit bien qu'on a des pathologies
aussi bien chez les très jeunes que chez
les plus âgés et que ça nécessite des
formations tout à fait particulières et
je crois que ça mérite évidemment qu'on
puisse regarder comment on peut
travailler là-dessus et j'en parlais à
La Capelle avec des professionnels
l'autre jour parce que on a aussi des
cas et on ne peut pas les ignorer de
gens qui arrivent là boul au vendre
parce qu'ils ne savent pas comment
madame machant ou monsieur truc quelle
va être sa forme aujourd'hui et ça c'est
quand même un sujet qui nécessite
évidemment qu'on y attache la plus
grande importance donc vraiment je je
veux vous dire combien je suis sensible
à ce sujet en ce qui concerne ce que
Madame Guillotin a a bien voulu dire moi
je crois effectivement que l'activité
physique adapté est vraiment un sujet
tout à fait important merci pour le le
crédit d'intention que vous vous avez
bien voulu mettre en avant les pas dors
les murs pourquoi pas la coordination
des soins je pense que c'est un
véritable sujet maintenant vous faisiez
allusion à une difficulté qui est celle
de des médecins on va pas se renvoyer à
la balle sur qui est responsable de quoi
la seule chose que l'on sait c'est que
le numérus apertus c'est 10300 médecins
par an mais qu'il faut 10 ans pour les
former donc on peut se raconter ce qu'on
veut on a encore à peu près 5 ans devant
nous qui vont être 5 années compliquées
le temps que c'est différents que ces
différents médecins puissent être
opérationnel et puis je crois qu'il faut
aussi qu'on se dise que ces médecins ils
ont des choix de vie et qu'on le veuille
ou non il faut aussi qu'on en tienne
compte parce que le choix de vie du il
faut pas qu'on imagine que on va d'un
claquement de doigt leur dire vous
faites si ou vous faites ça ils
considèrent que l'effort qu'ils font ils
le font en étant externe et en étant
interne et en étant à l'hôpital et ils
considèrent pas qu'ils ont une dette
après et je crois que c'est important
qu'on l'IT en tête parce que ça
nécessite des réponses supplé émentaire
en en terme de temps médical moi je suis
là pour dire les choses telles que je
les vis et pas ne rêvons pas ensemble
madame douanau merci d'avoir dit que ça
répondait à quelques questions et qu'il
y avait quelques frustration évidemment
on le sait vous connaissez le sujet des
finances publiques et toute la question
là-dessus sur ce grand ministère c'est
évidemment un double enjeu à chaque fois
que des gens retournent vers l'emploi je
retrouve une marge de manœuvre pour le
reste et je crois que ça c'est un point
qu'il faut qu'on ait en tête parce que
Ben évidemment tout ça c'est l'argent
des Français il y a pas d'argent magique
qui tombe de quelque part que ce soit
donc plus on arrivera effectivement et
je suis consciente quelqu'un parmi vous
l'a dit aujourd'hui c'est vrai que la
situation de l'emploi est moins bonne
aujourd'hui qu'n été l'année dernière
donc tout ça il faut savoir en tenir
compte mais je crois que c'est c'est un
point important après sur les épades moi
je suis pas là pour condamner les épades
mais je suis là pour dire quand même que
j'entends qu' y a des endroits où
certains épades ne trouvent pas leur
public je là encore je pèse mes mots
donc toute la question c'est comment on
arrive à trouver cet équilibre parce que
oui il y a des pathologies du grand âge
qui relèvent totalement de l'hépade et
pour lesquelles les familles n'ont pas
d'autre choix donc la question c'est
comment on a effectivement cette
capacité à répondre c'est pas simple
mais il faut qu'on puisse en parler ce
que disait alors madame parsant pouli
j'espère que je n'écorche pas votre nom
ah pour pouli pardon excusez-moi madame
euh alors 5 ministres en 5
ans bon non non mais je vous en
prie 5 ministres en 5 ans vous
m'accorderez que j'y suis pour rien euh
sur sur on est d'accord bon après vous
dire quand même que évidemment je suis à
la disposition des parlementaires j'ai
déjà été au ban sur deux textes je l'ai
dit la proposition de résolution je
l'étais hier sur les a et je serai là
autant que nécessaire parce que c'est
c'est évident qu'il faut qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble alors après je suis
consciente qu'on sera pas toujours
d'accord maintenant je pense qu'on peut
trouver des point pour avancer parce que
les métiers de l'humain méritent une
reconnaissance parce que s'il y a pas de
reconnaissance il y a pas d'attractivité
et que l'enjeu c'est quand même avant
tout celui-là et que c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut dans le contexte
budgétaire qui est le nôre on trouve des
solutions madame la rapporteur Himbert
l'accueil familial vous avez raison on
voudrait même vous proposer mes madame
monsieur le rapporteur peut-être de
réintroduire un article puisque on peut
encore discuter sur ce texte c'est
quelque chose qu'on est prêt à regarder
avec vous parce que incontestablement
c'est une des réponsse et il y a quelque
chose à faire deuxème élément sur les
siades ben voilà une des raisons
intéressantes de ce grand ministère
c'est que j'ai peut-être une capacité à
apporter des réponses en matière de
statut donc on va regarder ça et on va
regarder ce que l'on peut faire donc
monsieur le Président désolé pour ces
réponses un peu brouillones mais je
regarde le temps euh je voudrais vous
remercier de m'avoir consacrer ce temps
et vous dire que j'auraai plaisir à être
au ban la semaine prochaine à vos côtés
sur le sujet merciis merci pour votre
intervention et la précision quand même
de vos questions voilà de vos réponses
pardon très bien donc rendez-vous
rendez-vous à partir de de la semaine
prochaine je rappelle que nous avons un
texte en commission qui débute et donc
je compte sur vous dans vous avez 4
minutes pour descendre en séance merci
beaucoup